hello world my name is David J Ma and
I'm a professor of computer science at
Harvard University today I've been asked
to explain algorithms in five levels of
increasing difficulty algorithms are
important because they really are
everywhere not only in the physical
world but certainly in the virtual world
as well and in fact what excites me
about algorithms is that they really
represent an opportunity to solve
problems and I dare say no matter what
you do in life all of us have problems
to
solve so I'm a computer science
professor so I spend a lot of time with
computerss how would you define a
computer for them well a computer is
electronic like a phone but it's um a
rectangle and you like can type like
tick tick tick and you work on it nice
do you know any of the parts that are
inside of a computer um no can I explain
a couple of them to you yeah so like
inside of every computer is some kind of
brain and the technical term for that is
CPU or Central processing unit and those
are the pieces of Hardware that know how
to respond to those instructions like
moving up or down or left or right knows
how to do math like addition and
subtraction and then there's at least
one other type of Hardware inside of a
computer called memory or Ram if you've
heard of this I know memory because you
have to memorize stuff yeah exactly and
computers have even different types of
memory they have what's called Ram
random access memory which is where your
games where your programs are stored
while they being used but then it also
has a a hard drive or a solid state
drive which is where your data your high
scores your documents once you start
writing essays and and stories in the
future stays there stays permanently so
even if the power goes out the computer
can still remember that information it's
still there because the computer can't
just like delete all the words itself
because your fingers can only do that
like you have to use your finger to
delete all the stuff exactly have you
heard of an algorithm before um yes
algorithm is a list of instructions to
tell people what to do or like a robot
what to do yeah exactly it's so it's
just stepbystep instructions for doing
something for solving a problem for yeah
so like if you have a bedtime routine
then first you say I get dressed I brush
my teeth I read a little story and then
I go to bed all right well how about
another algorithm like um what do you
tend to eat for for lunch any types of
sandwiches you like uh I eat peanut
butter and let me get some supplies from
the cupboard here so should we make an
algorithm together for why don't we do
it this way why don't we pretend like
I'm a computer or maybe I'm a robot so I
only understand your instructions and so
I want you to feed me no pun intended an
algorithm so step-by-step instructions
for solving this problem but remember
algorithms you have to be precise you
have to give the right instructions the
right instructions just do it for me
soep step one was what open the bag okay
opening the bag of bread stop now grab
the bread and put it on the plate grab
the bread and put it on the
plate take all the bread back and put it
back in there so that's like an undo
command little control Z okay take one
bread and put it on the plate take the
lid off the peanut butter okay take the
lid off the peanut butter put the lid
down okay take the knife take the knife
put the blade inside the peanut butter
and spread the peanut butter on the
bread I'm going to take out some peanut
butter and I'm going to spread the
peanut butter on the bread I put a lot
of peanut butter on because I love
peanut butter apparently I thought I was
messing with you here but I think you're
happy with this Put The Knife down and
then grab one bread and put it on top of
the second bread
sideways
sideways like put it flat on oh flat
ways okay and now done you're done with
your sandwich should we take a delicious
bite yep let's take a bite okay here we
go what would be the next step be you
here clean all this mess up clean all
this mess up right we made an algorithm
step-by-step instructions for solving
some problem and if you think about now
how we made peanut butter and jelly
sandwiches sometimes we were imprecise
you didn't give me quite enough
information to do the algorithm
correctly and that's why I took out so
much bread Precision being very very
correct with your instructions is so
important in the real world because for
instance when you're using the worldwide
web and you're searching for something
on Google or being you want to do the
right thing so like if you type in just
Google then you won't find the answer to
your question pretty much everything we
do in life is an algorithm even if we
don't use that fancy word to describe it
because you and I are sort of following
instructions either that we came up with
ourselves or maybe our parents told us
how to do these things and so those are
just algorithms but when you start using
algorithms in uh computers that's when
you start writing
code what do you know about algorithms
nothing really um at all honestly I
think it's just probably a way to store
information um in computers and I dare
say even though you might not have put
this word on it odds are you executed as
a human multiple algorithms today even
before you came here today like what
were a few things that you did I got
ready okay and get ready what does that
mean brushing my teeth brushing my hair
okay put getting dressed okay so all of
those frankly if we really um Dove more
deeply could be broken down into
stepbystep instructions and presumably
your mom your dad someone in the past
sort of programmed you as a human to
know what to do and then after that as a
smart human you can sort of take it from
there and you don't need their help
anymore but that's kind of what we're
doing when we program computer something
maybe even more familiar nowadays like
odds are you have a cell phone your
contacts or your dress book but let me
ask you why that is like why does Apple
or Google or anyone else bother
alphabetizing your contacts I just
assumed it would be easier to navigate
what if your friend happened to be at
the very bottom of this randomly
organized list like why is that a
problem like he or she is still there I
guess it would take a while to get to
while you're scrolling that in of itself
is kind of a problem or it's an
inefficient solution to the problem so
it turns out that back in my day before
there were cell phones like everyone's
numbers from high schools like were
literally printed in a book and everyone
in my town and my city my state was
printed in an actual phone book even if
you've never seen this technology before
how would you propose verbally to find
John in this phone book or I would just
flip through and just look for the J I
guess yeah so let me propose that we
start that way I could just start at the
beginning and step by step I could just
look at each page looking for John
looking for John now even if you've
never seen this here technology before
it turns out this is exactly what your
phone could be doing in software like
someone from Google or Apple or the like
they could write software that uses a
technique in programming known as a loop
and a loop as the word implies is just
sort of do something again and again
what if instead of starting from the
beginning and going one page at a time
what if I or what if your phone goes
like two pages or two names at a time
would this be correct do you think well
you could skip over John I think in what
sense if he's in one of the middle pages
that you skipped over yeah so sort of
accidentally and frankly with like 50/50
probability John could get sandwiched in
between two pages but does that mean I
have to throw that algorithm out alt
together maybe you could use that
strategy until you get close to the
section and then switch to going one by
one okay that's nice so you could kind
of like go twice as fast but then kind
of pump the brakes as you near your exit
on the highway or in this case near the
J section of the book exactly and maybe
alternatively if I get to like a b c d e
f g h i j k if I get to the K section
then I could just double back like one
page just to make sure John didn't get
sandwiched between those pages so the
nice thing about that second algorithm
is that I'm flying through the phone
book like two pages at a time so 2 4 6 8
10 12 it's not perfect it's not
necessarily correct but it is if I just
take like one extra step so I think it's
fixable but what your phone is probably
doing and frankly what I and like my
parents and grandparents used to do back
in the day is we'd probably go roughly
to the middle of the phone book here and
just intuitively if this is an
alphabetized phone book in English what
section am I probably going to find
myself in roughly K okay so I'm in the K
section is John going to be to the left
or to the right to the left yeah so John
is going to be to the left to the right
and what we can do here though your
phone does something smarter is tear the
problem in half throw half of the
problem away being left with just 500
pages now but what might I next do I
could sort of naively just start at the
beginning again but we've learned to do
better I can go roughly to the middle
here do it again yeah exactly so now
maybe I'm in the E section which is a
little to the left so John is clearly
going to be to the right so I can again
tear the problem portly in half throw
this half of the problem away and I
claim now that if we started with a
th000 Pages now we've gone to 500 250
now we're really moving quick
not on that page and I can call him
roughly how many steps might this third
algorithm take if I started with a th000
Pages then went to 500 250 125 like how
many times can you divide 1,000 and half
maybe 10 that's roughly 10 because in
the first algorithm looking again for
someone like Zoe in the worst case might
have to go all the way through thousand
pages but the second algorithm you said
was 500 maybe 500 in1 essentially the
same thing so twice as fast but this
third and final algorithm is sort of
fundamentally faster because you're
you're sort of dividing and conquering
it in half and half and half not just
taking one or two bites out of it at of
a time so this of course is not how we
used to use phone books back in the day
since otherwise they'd be single use
only but it is how your phone is
actually searching for zoy for John for
anyone else but it's doing it in
software oh that's cool so here we've
happened to focus on searching
algorithms looking for John in the phone
book but the technique we just used can
indeed be called divide and conquer
where you take a big problem and you
divide and conquer that is you try to
chop it up into smaller smaller smaller
pieces a more sophisticated type of
algorithm at least depending on how you
implement it something known as a
recursive algorithm recursive algorithm
is essentially an algorithm that uses
itself to solve the exact same problem
again and again but chops it smaller and
smaller and smaller
[Music]
ultimately hi my name is Patricia
Patricia nice to meet you where are you
a student at I'm starting my senior year
now at NYU oh nice and what have you
been studying the past few years I study
computer science and data science if you
were chatting with a non-cs nonata
science friend of yours like how would
you explain to them what an algorithm is
some kind of like systematic way of like
solving a problem or like a set of like
steps to kind of solve a certain like
problem you have so you probably recall
learning topics like binary search
versus linear search and the like so
I've come here uh complete with a actual
chalkboard with some magnetic numbers on
it here like how would you tell a friend
to sort these I think one of the first
things we learned was something called
bubble sort it was kind of like focusing
on like smaller like bubbles I guess I
would say it like of the problem like
looking at like smaller segments rather
than like the whole thing at once what
is I think very true about what you're
hinting at is that bubble sort really
focuses on like local small problems
rather than taking a step back trying to
fix the whole thing let's just fix the
obvious problem in front of us so for
instance when we're trying to get from
smallest to largest and the first two
things we see are eight followed by one
this looks like a problem cuz it's out
of order so what would be the simplest
fix the least amount of work we can do
to at least fix one problem just like
switch those two numbers cuz one is
obviously smaller than eight perfect so
we just swap those two then you would
switch those again yeah so that further
improves the situation and you can kind
of see it that the one and the two are
now in place how about 8 and six switch
it again switch those again 8 and three
switch it again
and conversely now the one and the two
are closer to and coincidentally are
exactly where we want them to be so are
we done no okay so obviously not but
what could we do now to further improve
the situation go through it again but
like you don't need to check the last
one anymore because we know like that
number is bubbled up to the top Yeah
because it has indeed bubbled all the
way to the top so one and two yeah keep
it as is okay two and six keep it as is
okay six and three then you switch it
okay we switch or swap those six and
four swap it again okay so four and uh
six and seven uh keep it okay seven and
five swap it okay and then I think per
your point we're pretty darn close let's
go through once more one and two Keep It
2 three keep it 3 four keep it 4 six
keep it 6 five and then switch it all
right we'll switch this and now to your
point we don't need to bother with the
ones that already bubbled their way up
now we're 100% sure it's sorted yeah and
certainly the search engines of the
world Google and Bing and so forth they
probably don't keep web pages in sorted
order because that would be a crazy long
list when you're just trying to search
the data but there's probably some
algorithm underlying what they do and
they probably similarly just like we do
a bit of work upfront to get things
organized even if it's not strictly
sorted in the same way so that people
like you and me and others can find that
same information so how about social
media can you Invision where the
algorithms are in that world like maybe
for example like Tik Tok like the for
you page it's kind of like
cuz those are like Rec like
recommendations right it's like sort of
like Netflix recommendations except more
constant because it's just like every
video you scroll it's like that's a new
recommendation basically and it's like
based on like what you've liked
previously what you've like saved
previously what you search up so I would
assume there's some kind of algorithm
there kind of figuring out like what to
put on your foru page absolutely just
trying to keep you presumably more
engaged so the better the algorithm is
the better your engagement is maybe the
more money the company then makes on the
platform and so forth so it all sort of
feeds together together but what you're
describing really is more artificially
intelligent if I may because presumably
there's not someone at Tik Tok or any of
these social media companies saying if
Patricia likes this post then show her
this post if she likes this post then
show her this other post because the
code would sort of grow infinitely long
and there's just way too much content
for a programmer to be having those
kinds of conditionals those those
decisions being made behind the scenes
so it's probably a little more
artificially intelligent and in that
sense You have topics like neuron
networks and uh machine learning which
really describe taking as input things
like what you watch what you click on
what your friends watch what they click
on and sort of trying to infer from that
instead what should we show Patricia or
her friends next okay yeah yeah that
makes like the distinction more makes
more sense now
yeah I am currently a fourth year PhD
student at NYU I do robot learning so
that's half and half Robotics and
Mission learning sounds like you've
dabbled with quite a few algorith so how
does one actually research algorithms or
invent algorithms the most important was
just trying to think about
inefficiencies and also think about
Connecting Threads the way I think about
it is that algorithm for me is not just
about the way of doing something but
it's about doing something efficiently
learning algorithms are practically
everywhere now CU Google I would say for
example is learning every day about like
oh what what articles with links might
be better than others and reranking them
um there are recommender systems all
around us
right like content feeds and social
media or you know like YouTube or
Netflix what we see is in a large part
determined by this kind of learning
algorithms nowadays there's a lot of
concerns around some applications of
machine learning and like deep fakes
where it can kind of learn how I talk
and learn how you talk and even how we
look and generate videos of us we're
doing this for real but you could
imagine a computer synthesizing this
conversation eventually but how does it
even know what I sound like and what I
look like and how to replicate that all
of this learning algorithms that we talk
about right uh a lot like what goes in
there is just lots and lots of data so
data goes in something else comes out
what comes out is whatever objective
function that you optimize for like
where is the line between algorithms
that like play games with and without AI
I think when I started off my undergrad
the current AI machine learning was not
very much synonymous okay and even in my
undergraduate in the AI class they
learned a lot of classical gorithms for
game plays like for example the AAR
search right that's a very simple
example of how you can play a game
without having anything learned this is
very much oh you are at a game State you
just search down see what are the
possibilities and then you pick the best
possibility that it can see versus what
you think about when you think about I
gameplay like the alpha zero for example
or Alpha star or there are a lot of you
know like fancy new machine learning
agents that are you know even like
learning very difficult games like go
and those are learned agents as in they
are getting better as they play more and
more games and as they get more games
they kind of refine their strategy based
on the data that they seen and once
again this high level abstraction is
still the same you see a lot of data and
you learn from that right but the
question is what is objective function
that you're optimizing for is it winning
this game is it forcing a tie or is it
you know like opening a door in a
kitchen so if the world is very much
focused on supervised unsupervised
reinforcement learning now like what
comes next 5 10 years where's the world
going I think that this is just U going
to be more and more I don't want to use
the word encroachment but that's what it
feels like of algorithms into our
everyday life like even when I was
taking the train here right the trains
are being routed with algorithms but
this has existed for you know like 50
years probably but as I was coming here
as I was checking my phone those are
different algorithms and you know
they're they're kind of getting all
around us getting they're with us all
the time they're making our life better
most places most cases and I think
that's just going to be continuation of
all of those and it feels like they're
even in places you wouldn't expect and
there's just so much data about you and
me and everyone else online and this
data is being mind and analyzed and
influencing things we see and here it
would seem so there is sort of a
Counterpoint which might be good for the
marketers but not necessarily good for
you and me as individuals you know like
we're human beings but for someone we
might be just a pair of eyes who are you
know carrying a wallet and are there to
buy things but there is so much more
potential for this algorithms to just
make our life better without you know
like changing much about our
life I'm Chris Wiggins from associate
professor of Applied Mathematics at
Columbia I'm also the chief data
scientist of the New York Times the data
science team at the New York Times
develops and deploys machine learning
for Newsroom and business problems but I
would say the things that we do mostly
you don't see but it might be things
like personalization algorithm are
recommending different content and do
data scientists which is rather distinct
from the phrase computer scientist do
data scientists still think in terms of
algorithms as driving a lot of it oh
absolutely yeah in fact so in data
science and Academia often the role of
the algorithm is the optimization
algorithm that helps you find the best
model or the best description of a data
set okay in data science and industry
the goal often it's centered around an
algorithm which becomes a data product
right so a data scientist in Industry
might be developing and deploying the
algorithm which means not only
understanding the algorithm and its
statistical performance but also all of
the software engineering around systems
integration making sure that that
algorithm receives input that's reliable
and has output that's useful as well as
I would say the organizational
integration which is how does a
community of people like the set of
people working at the New York Times
integrate that algorithm into their
process interesting and I feel like AI
based startups are all their R and
certainly within Academia are there
connections between Ai and the world of
data science absolutely the algorithms
that there in can you connect those dots
for you're right that AI as a field has
really exploded I would say particularly
many people experienced a chatbot that
was really really good today when people
say I AI they're often thinking about
large language models or they're
thinking about generative AI or they
might be thinking about a chatbot one
thing to keep in mind is a chatbot is a
special case of generative AI which is a
special case of using large language
models which is a special case of using
machine learning generally which is what
most people mean by AI you may have
moments that are um what John kthy
called look M No Hands results where you
do some fantastic trick and you're not
quite sure how it worked I think it's
still very much early days large
language models is still in the point of
what might be called alchemy that people
are building large language models
without a real clear a priori sense of
what the right design is for a right
problem many people are trying different
things out often in large companies
where they can afford to have many
people trying things out seeing what
works publishing that instantiating it
as a product and that itself is part of
the scientific process I would think too
yeah very much well science and
engineering because often you're
building a thing and the thing does
something amazing to large extent we are
still looking for basic theoretical
results around why deep neural networks
generally work why are they able to
learn so well they're huge billions of
parameter models and it's difficult for
us to interpret how they are able to do
what they do and is this a good thing do
you think or an inevitable thing that we
the programmers we the computer
scientist the data science who are
inventing these things can't actually
explain how they work because I feel
like friends of mine industry even when
it's something simple and relatively
familiar like autocomplete they can't
actually tell me like why that name is
appearing at the top of the list whereas
years ago when these algorithms were
more deterministic and more procedural
you could even point to the line that
made that name bubble up to the top so
is this a good thing a bad thing that
we're sort of losing control perhaps in
some sense of the algorithm it has risks
I don't know that I would say that it's
good or bad but I would say there's lots
of scientific precedent there are times
when an algorithm works really well and
we have finite understanding of why it
works or a model works really well and
sometimes we have very little
understanding of why it works the way it
does in classes I teach certainly spend
a lot of time on fundamentals algorithms
that have been taught in classes for
decades now whether it's binary search
linear search bubble swort selection
sort or the like but are if we're
already at the point where I can pull up
chat GPT copy paste a whole bunch of
numbers or words and say sort these for
me does it really matter how chat GPT is
sorting it does it really matter to me
as the user how the software is sorting
it like do the fundamentals become more
dated and less important do you think
now you're talking about the ways in
which code and computation is a special
case of Technology right so for driving
a car you may not necessarily need to
know much about organic chemistry even
if if the organic chemistry is how the
car works right so you can drive the car
and use it in different ways without
understanding much about the
fundamentals so similarly with
computation we're at a point where the
computation is so high level right as
you you know you can import pyit learn
and you can go from zero to machine
learning and 30 seconds it's depending
on what level you want to understand the
technology where in the stack so to
speak um it's possible to understand it
and make wonderful things and Advance
the world without understanding it at
the particular level of somebody who
actually might have originally designed
the actual optimization algorithm I
should say though for many of the
optimization algorithms there are cases
where an algorithm works really well and
we publish a paper and there's a proof
in the paper and then years later people
realize actually that prove was wrong
and we're really still not sure why that
optimization works but it works really
well or it inspires people to make new
optimization algorithms so I I do think
that the the goal of understanding
algorithms is Loosely coupled to our
progress in advancing grade algorithms
but they don't always necessarily have
to require each other and for those
students especially or even adults who
are thinking of now steering into
computer science into programming who
were really jazzed about heading in that
direction up until for instance November
of 2022 when all of a sudden for many
people it looked like the world was now
changing and now maybe this isn't such a
promising path this isn't such a
lucrative path anymore are llms are
tools like chat GPT reason not to
perhaps steer into the field large
language models are a particular
architecture for predicting let's say
the next word or a set of tokens more
generally the algorithm comes in when
you think about how is that llm to be
trained or also how to be fine-tuned so
the P of GPT is a pre-trained algorithm
the idea is that you train a large
language model on some Corpus of text
could be encyclopedias or textbooks or
what have you and then you might want to
fine-tune that model around some
particular task or some particular
subset of texts so both of those are
examples of training algorithms so I
would say people's perception of
artificial intelligence has really
changed a lot in the last 6 months
particularly around November of 2022
when people experienced a really good
chatbot the technology though had been
around already before academics had
already been working with chat gpt3
before that and GPT 2 and gpt1 and and
for many people it sort of opened up
this conversation about what is
artificial intelligence and what could
we do with this and what are the
possible good and bad right like any
other piece of technology cransberg
first law of technology technology is
neither good nor bad nor is it neutral
every time we have some new technology
we should think about its capabilities
and the good and the possible bad as
with any area of study algorithms offer
a spectrum from the most basic to the
most advanced and even if right now the
most advanced of the those algorithms
feels Out Of Reach because you just
don't have that background with each
lesson you learn with each algorithm you
study that endgame becomes closer and
closer such that it will before long be
accessible to you and you will be at the
end of that most advanced
[Music]
Spectrum